Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry, I'm... I literally got home from my dance classes, like, um, 30 minutes ago.
I haven't... I didn't want to eat before my dance classes, so...
I had to, like... I had to walk dad, and then I had to...
Oh my God, MasterDrop!
Thank you for the 50 gifted shits!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, thank you so much!
Oh my God, we got some fresh tomatoes, dragoons!
Are you guys hungry?
Anyway, um, it's not cheat week this time.
It's not cheat day this time.
I got my grandma bread, and I used a... I got my brie cheese spread.
I put some chicken on it, and then I was like...
I was scared there was gonna be mold on it, because I was like...
It was in the fridge, and I was like, Google, how long can bread be in fridges?
And they're like, 14 days.
I was like, has it been 14 days yet?
So I checked for mold.
I made sure to check for mold.
I was a little concerned, but I made sure there was no mold growing on my bread.
And there wasn't.
So I was like, all right, it can't be that bad.
Like, if I don't see the mold, it's okay.
I made sure.
At least I checked.
I remember in university, I...
Because like, I was a very sheltered child.
So like, I didn't understand the concept of mold.
Like, I'm not joking.
I didn't realize mold existed when I went to university.
Because I didn't realize it can grow on bread.
So like, so I put my bread...
So like, I had a point where I was like, all right, I'm gonna go on a bread diet.
I'll just eat bread and hummus dip.
So I was like, obviously that wasn't healthy, but I was in university.
So I was just like...
I was like, we were doing a lot of unhealthy stuff in university.
So I was like, I was very sheltered.
No, I was a very sheltered child.
So I didn't really understand like, mold can grow on things.
Because like, you know, my parents would be like, eat this.
I'm like, I didn't understand anything.
So I was like, all right, I'm gonna...
And then like, you know, it was room temperature.
And you know, bread's supposed to be up room temperature maximum four days.
I didn't put it in the fridge because I had like, a mini fridge.
It didn't fit in the mini fridge.
So I was like, I'm just gonna put it out room temperature.
And like, obviously, I was just eating bread every day.
Like, just bread and hummus every day.
And then I noticed, what is these things growing on my bread?
I was like, I'll just rip it all out.
And then he...
And then after, I was like, wait, I don't think bread is supposed to do that.
I was like, wait a minute.
I don't think bread is supposed to do that.
So, you know, it kept getting more.
And I was like, oh, maybe...
And I like, I was like, wait, is this what mold is?
Is this like...
And so that's when I discovered, I discovered what mold was.
So yeah, I checked the grandma bread.
And I was like, all right, the grandma bread has no mold growing.
I put it on the fridge.
And like, everything is fine.
So I cut it.
And I was like, I cut it with my bread knife.
And I was like, no, nothing's wrong.
I guess I can eat the soap.
I don't know.
If later today, if later today my stomach does not feel well, then maybe the mold is like...
Maybe I did not check as well as I thought I did.
So we'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
So yeah, also another update regarding the shower curtains.
I didn't realize that...
Yeah, I checked every length, by the way.
I checked everything.
It's not like in...
Like, I didn't put it at room temperature.
I put it in my fridge.
But anyway, I don't remember how long this bread has been in the fridge, but it seems okay.
Anyway, update regarding the shower curtains.
I didn't realize that like, height-wise was a thing.
I thought shower curtains were universal regarding like, the height of a shower curtain.
So like, obviously, I hung the shower curtains, but like, it just...
Let's just say it doesn't go all the way down.
But it still works!
It's like, it's like, you know, it's like a just fit scenario, but like, it works, I think.
I mean, I took a shower, and like, I don't think any of the water came out.
So like, I think it's working, but I think I have to like, test it out a bit more to see if it...
And see if the...
Like, you know, if see it is 100%.
Like, I don't know if the water could slip through the cracks of it.
Like, it just, it just sort of fits.
Because like, it's a bathtub shower.
So like, it just touches the tub.
Just like, it just touches the tub.
So I was like, oh, I don't know.
I'm just like, wait, shower...
I thought, I thought the shower curtain is like, universal.
I didn't realize it's like, a specific height.
It looked really long.
I was like, it looks really long.
I thought, I thought it would go down a little bit more.
It's sort of working.
Also, Mike, thank you for the magenta soup.
Ah, thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki, today is my birthday.
Just wanted to say thanks for always making us smile.
Thank you for the magenta soup, Mike.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Mike.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Anyway, I have a lot of other life updates.
But like, those are like, my top two.
Anyway, just got back from dance lessons.
It's gonna be...
Oh my god, I was, I was so fucking tired.
I was like, I was like, I was so dead inside for the dance lessons.
It's a lot of dancing.
Like, I was like, I can do this.
I can, I can, I can do this, Doki.
You can, you can do dance lessons almost every day before, before you gotta do the 3D.
It's alright.
And now I'm like, maybe it's not alright.
Maybe, maybe, maybe it was a mistake trying to do dance lessons every day.
I was like, and I was like, can you do 10 AM?
And I was like, I can totally do 10 AM.
That's, that's good.
I can totally do 10 AM.
And now I'm like, oh, maybe.
Why did I, why did I pick 10 in the morning?
It's like when you're doing university classes, and you're like, I could totally do morning classes in university.
I can, I can, I can definitely do morning classes in university.
And then, you know, you sign up for the morning classes, and you're like, oh, why did I pick, wait, wait a minute.
Also, I need to take off my contact lenses.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need, I need to take them off real quick.
Oh my god, I don't like playing video games with my contact lenses on.
I need to, like, buy new glasses, too.
Because, like, my new, my old pair has, is like, like, the degrees are okay.
But, like, um, but, like, uh, I just feel like, uh, the lens, I haven't bought new glasses in a long time.
And, oh my god, it's so hard to adjust back to the degree again when you have your glasses on.
Um, I buy Lindbergh glasses.
I don't know.
It's just, like, my parents always bought me Lindbergh.
They're very, I know, they're very, they're a very expensive brand.
They're, like, one of the lightest glasses out there.
But, like, I'm so used to, I'm so used to wearing them that it feels weird if I wear, like, heavier glasses.
Um, anyway, um, but yeah, I had, oh my gosh.
I, I, god, it's just, um, that, oh my god, it's just, oh, the dance lessons, the morning dance lessons.
I even asked, like, can I, can I, like, uh, leave class 30 minutes early?
I was, like, I was, like, can I leave class 30 minutes early, please?
I, I don't, I don't, I don't want to do two hours.
I'm, I'm so over it.
I'm, I'm done.
I'm so done.
And they're, like, yeah, you can.
I was, like, I have a busy day today.
Also, I checked out the new Death Note game.
Oh my god, it's so complicated.
By the way, um, uh, um, it's basically, like, it is Among Us, but, like, it's much more complicated than normal Among Us.
There's, like, there's, like, you can talk to Kira.
So, like, you can hand, you can basically swap Kiras.
So you can, like, give the Death Notes to other, uh, other Kira followers, and then you can swap Kiras, basically.
And, like, so, like, if they say, oh, I think you're Kira, but if you gave your Death Note to somebody else, then, um, and you, they nominate you as a suspect, you don't, you, you basically are safe.
So, like, they can basically swap the Death Notes everywhere and stuff.
And then, like, and then, oh my, it's so, it's actually really complicated.
And there's, like, in-game voice chat, too.
So you can talk to people in-game.
But, like, the funny thing is that in the settings, it doesn't tell you what button is the in-game voice chat.
I was, like, trying to, I was looking through the settings, and I was, like, which one?
Because there's push-to-talk.
There's proximity chat, but there's also push-to-talk.
So I was, like, obviously, we should do push-to-talk.
Oh, yeah, it has a built-in proximity chat.
But, like, I don't know how push-to-talk works for it, because it doesn't say in the settings.
But it says it exists.
And you can also, like, use a transmitter to, like, just talk to Kira.
So you can, like, Kira can, like, communicate with you and stuff.
So, like, he, like, and then, like, you're supposed to figure out which one's L and which one's Kira.
And then when you're in the Among Us meeting, you can do, like, if you're L or Kira, you can, or if you're L, you can do, like, anonymous messages and be, like, L thinks this person is Kira.
But you don't know who's L.
You don't know who it is.
So, like, it just comes up in the meeting room.
And the L would be, like, I think this person is Kira.
But you don't know who it is.
It said that.
It just shows up.
It's, like, there's so much mechanics.
I was, like, it's so interesting.
I don't, I told the girls, because I told the girls, I was, like, there is a tutorial and it is a little bit confusing.
So, so, I was, like, I was, like, you guys should try it.
Look, look into the tutorial, because I was, like, there were so many things going on.
Anyway, today is the newest season of Apex Legends.
I didn't leak anything, but I did give you guys a little hint, because I was invited to check out the, like, I, it wasn't a play test, but it was more so of, like, a video demonstration of all the new updates before the update came out.
I think, like, two weeks ago.
And for those who don't know, the time to kill is even higher now.
It's, it's because support, they basically retooled support into something crazy good.
Like, they basically made support insane.
So, like, you can do, so when you rez somebody as a support character, they have regen and everything, so they can regenerate and they have faster revive speed.
And then they retooled Lifeline to have different abilities, so her ult is different, her abilities are different, everything is basically different.
So support is meta now.
So, yeah, they basically, if you're a support character and you revive someone, they have regen.
So it's not like they're, yeah, they're super busted.
And apparently you have two supports, you can chain the rez because it's regenerating.
So support mains are basically eating good today.
Other than that, they changed the battle pass, but who cares about that?
By the way, today I got sponsored by Apex.
Huge shout out to EA and Respawn for sponsoring me today.
If you guys didn't watch, see the video, they sponsored me to make a video to talk about my Apex story.
So, like, how I got started with Apex and everything and, like, what I love about the game and everything.
So please check it out.
I know it's, like, in the video category, but it's supposed to be a short and I don't...
Apparently you can now upload three minute, like, up to three minutes for a short, but it's, like, super buggy and everything.
So, like, yeah, but yeah, check it out.
Check out the sponsored video.
It always is really amazing to be sponsored by Apex because, like, you know, I played that game for free for so long and now they pay me to play.
And now they pay me to play their game.
And, you know, it's nice, you know, it's very nice.
So, yes.
So today we're going to be checking out what they change when it comes to Apex.
So I'll show you guys the lifeline changes and everything.
I should really look at the patch.
I never look at the patch notes.
I just learn it live.
But yeah, season 23.
So it's today's lifeline day.
Okay, launch royale.
Basically, the Gibby shield.
It's now... what was it?
It was like from 30.
The cooldown is now like 17 seconds instead of 30 seconds, which is really crazy.
Ghostly Trash Can, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
My birthday is in a couple of days.
Can I get an early happy birthday?
Also, hello, Dragos.
Thank you for your very first super chat, Trash Can.
Thank you.
Of course.
Happy early birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy early birthday to Trash Can.
Yeah!
All right, let's see the new video.
I... oh.
Oh my gosh, what the f...
Okay, I guess not.
It's so annoying.
I always have to like re-register.
Ever since I moved, they're always like, where are you?
I'm like, remember?
They never remember this advice.
It's so fucking annoying.
I don't know what to do.
They never remember it.
I've been... I have to do it every time I boot up Apex.
And it's so fucking annoying.
They're just like, who are you?
What are you doing here?
No!
Wait, I wanna watch!
I need to watch the video.
All right, there you go.
Why is it... oh my god, it's like the OG.
Oh.
Feels like the OG.
It's like... it's the OG season.
Yeah, it's like the season one.
This game has lore?
It used to be more lore.
Oh my god.
I don't know if he's gay, by the way.
You guys have no chance.
Unless you're... you're gay too.
I'm a dude, let's go!
I have a chance!
Is that Fuse?
Wait, who's you?
Oh my god, I'm...
Oh, y'all know I'm not gonna be killing anyone.
Oh my god, I'm better!
Blisk?
Oh, is that... oh, Blisk.
Oh, he's a villain from...
I don't remember.
It's been so long since I played Titanfall 2.
I don't remember the names.
I actually don't remember their names.
Oh my god!
Wait, this is actual OG!
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait!
This is like...
OG, OG Apex!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's crazy!
Oh my god, we're back!
We're back!
Oh, this is my prime.
This is... okay, I want to know.
This is my peak right here.
Oh, it's a...
Oh my god, and we're back!
Wait, is it...
Is it Classic King's Canyon?
No, I don't think so.
I... no, wait.
Did they bring back...
Did they bring back Classic King's Canyon?
Oh my god, we're...
Oh my god, we're back again!
Oh my... okay, okay, we gotta...
Why was it tutorial?
Oh, get me out of here.
I accidentally put tutorial.
Oh my god, we're back!
We're actually back!
Sorry, I went to tutorial.
I went back back.
Oh my god, Skulltown's back, baby!
I love OG Skulltown.
Actually...
Wait, did they revert everything including the bunny hop?
I would imagine.
Maybe you could like reverse bunny hop?
No, they didn't.
That would be so funny if they could...
If they reverse...
We could heal while bunny hopping.
I don't think we can.
I don't think we're back back.
There's no way.
There's no...
Wait, there is?!
We can...
Oh my
god!
Oh my...
Okay, wait, okay.
How do I get...
Damn it, I need to get a name.
Oh my god, we're actually back back.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, I'm actually really happy.
I learned how to...
I learned how to like heal bunny hop.
And then they took it away from me.
Okay, let's see.
Where...
Where are the names?
Oh my god, where the fuck are the...
Where...
Where are they?
Okay, there you go.
All right.
Okay.
Come on.
All right, nice.
All right.
Oh my god.
No, I can't get it correctly.
It's been too long.
Oh my god!
I'm doing it!
Oh, I can do it again!
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm really happy.
I'm actually so happy.
You know what I said?
I'm really happy, guys.
Like, I learned how to do that and then they fucking took it away.
So basically, for those who don't remember, it's basically...
If you close your eyes...
If you...
I did the thing.
Does it almost feel like nothing's changed at all?
Anyway, this is the new ult.
It's basically a shield and fast heals.
So...
Okay, I shouldn't have used it.
So if I do this...
And then...
Does it feel like...
Oh wait, I need to...
Does it feel like nothing's changed at all?
And you can...
And these move now.
These move now, by the way.
You can like, send it to your teammates and stuff and everything.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I'm so...
You guys don't understand.
I love healing.
Bhopping and healing.
Oh my god!
Maybe I'll try this season.
Wait, wait, I'm so happy.
I'm actually so happy.
Okay, and then you can glide.
I heard...
I know about the glide.
So...
Oh my god.
Watch this.
I'm sorry, I'm really kidding because like...
Oh my god, old Apex is back.
I love old Apex so much.
I can do this, guys.
I can do this.
Oh my god.
I can do this, guys.
You guys don't understand.
This is my favorite part.
This is literally...
This is my happy moment right here.
This is my happy...
I haven't done it in so long.
But I still got it.
I still got it.
I can still reverse Bhop heal.
Oh my god.
Okay, anyway.
This is my happy place.
They're gonna take it away and I'll be so sad again.
They're gonna...
I know they're gonna take this away from me.
What is the new abilities?
Increase the time before it runs out of fuel.
Okay, this one has to be good.
Tactical cooldown.
Increase the distance you can assign by 50.
I feel like the tactical cooldown would be better.
Oh, the muscle memory is coming back.
All right, what are the other things?
Okay.
Heal drone upgrades.
Rift relics.
Turn around provides contestants with powerful weapons.
New support class perks.
Can now move at a full speed while healing.
Healing amounts from small meds is doubled.
Support ledges now have 25% faster revives.
Um, the health regen will restore an ally to full health.
Oh my...
Full HP?
That's...
Oh, but you can stop it.
If they get damaged, you can...
They can stop the regen.
Oh, that's...
That's actually insane though.
Full HP...
If you revive somebody, they get full HP.
Full HP regen.
Um...
Support legends will also revive...
Receive this health regen if revived.
Okay.
Support legends can see mobile respawn beacons inside death boxes.
All right.
And collecting banners will automatically take a mobile respawn beacon and an ally death box.
Wow.
So basically, when you take the banner, you don't have to loot the box.
You can basically get the...
Um...
You can get the mobile thing instantly.
Okay.
Devotion is back on the floor.
Havoc...
Oh god.
Havoc is a care package weapon.
That sounds so fucking scary.
L-star is a gold gun.
Mastiff.
Uh...
Lupin.
Reset.
Boosted loader.
Gunshield generator.
Hammer point.
Um...
Guns.
I don't think it really matters too much.
Uh...
Revive.
Connuit.
What?
Each support character has different...
Okay.
What?
Wait.
Oh my god.
Surveillance drone now takes rain.
Oh, surveillance drone now takes rain.
Thank fucking god.
All right.
None of these are very important to me.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy, guys.
I'm so happy.
Each legend has had the majority of stats and abilities reverted to the first season.
You know what that means.
Wait!
Wait, does that mean Pathfinder's hitbox is back?
Wait, does that mean Pathfinder's hitbox is the same as...
Wait a minute.
Do you guys remember Pathfinder's hitbox?
Do you guys remember...
Pathfinder's hitbox?
It's back to first season.
I remember Pathfinder's...
No, it's the same!
No!
There's no way.
They must...
Oh my god, please.
Okay, we're gonna see.
I'm gonna see if the Pathfinder's hitbox is the same.
That's fine.
Oh my god, Wraith's insta kill.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, wait!
Wait!
Wraith's insta kill.
Oh my god, I remember.
Wait, okay.
We introduce Pudge Priestess now.
Infinity!
Jump on ziplines!
Okay, shields are not automatically regenerated.
Not exclusive to gold armor.
Oh my god, gold armor regen.
Oh my god.
Okay, armor core has...
Each piece is pickup only and does not evolve.
Oh my god, nice.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Okay, okay.
But they made the loot table in King's Canyon.
Fucking shit again.
If you guys don't remember, season one of King's Canyon loot pool was very, very bad.
Gold knockdown is self revive.
Gold backpack is fast heal.
Gold armor is shield regeneration.
No laser sights.
Okay, wait!
What was it on wingman?
That was super good.
Oh my god, wait.
Golden head...
Global headshot damage is now 2.0.
Regenerates on all weapons.
Fuck, what was the best guns in season one?
It's been so long!
Guys, I don't remember...
No!
Okay, I'll play Wraith.
Wait, sculpt!
R9 is back, baby!
R9 is back!
R9 wingman, we're fucking back!
You know what I look like.
Come find me.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It's like nothing's changed at all.
You close your eyes.
You're so back.
Oh my god, you're so fucking back.
I'm so happy.
I can't wait to blast people.
With an R9.
Oh, let's fucking go!
If you close your- We can put a sniper scope on the wingman again!
Wait, wait, can we actually?
Oh my god, let's go die.
Wait, we can stack this!
Let's go, let's go die, guys.
This is like a really bad idea.
But, because we landed late.
Okay.
Oh my god, did you- This is a very bad idea.
We were so back.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alrighty, let's go.
Wait, the wingman is shit with a digi in season one.
I remember the wingman not being the best with a digi.
I'll just put it on this one.
There we go.
There's nothing changed at all.
Can I close my eyes?
R400!
Wait, you're right!
The R400!
Okay, I'm gonna- Oh my god, it's so weird.
It's actually so fucking weird.
Grab a fucking armor, guys!
Oh my god, the fire rate is crazy.
I'm not used to it at all.
Oh fuck.
Let's see, we're fine.
It's been a while since I played wingman.
They don't know.
They actually don't know.
Oh yeah?
No.
Just armor swap.
It's literally- We're back!
Oh my god, there's a choke too.
Where?
Oh my god, the fucking fire rate!
Oh, you think I don't see you?
Oh yeah?
Oh shit, I thought that was a body.
Holy fuck.
I'm coming over, Pathfinder!
Oh wait, what?
This is not fair.
No!
Holy fuck!
I'm not used to the fire rate.
I'm not used to the wingman fire rate.
It's so weird.
It's actually so- It's so fast again!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's not my fault.
Our bloodhound was- Our bloodhound was a little special.
Our bloodhound was special.
Yeah!
Back when- Back when the game was all about skill.
Actually no, people die so fast.
Oh my god.
Okay, I want to know if Pathfinder's hitbox is the same.
Call him trash?
Okay, like, look.
I don't want to make fun of somebody who might be like, you know, having a rough- He might be a dad, okay?
He might have called off work.
He might have called off work today.
Be like, oh my god, season 23.
Season 23 is coming out.
I can't, I can't.
If you call him sick, you know, he's working a nine to five.
Then he's like, oh my god, I remember when I used to play season one before I got this job.
Pathfinder's hitbox?
I thought they did!
Season one, um...
Season one, Pathfinder hitbox was like, so fucking broken.
He was like a little skeleton.
Uh, call him sick to throw- Oh, shit, I went back to work.
Just went back to work.
Oh my god.
All right, we'll see.
We'll see if the- We'll see if Pathfinder's hitbox is the same or not.
If it's still like, it's so weird just seeing this.
Even the icons are like, the old icons too, which is- Which is so weird to see.
Like, I'm pretty sure that was not Wraith's icon back, like now.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh!
Yeah, the 144p icons.
Oh, it's so good to be back.
I'm so happy.
Happy, happy, happy.
The nostalgia.
I hate this game.
Oh, but you always come back.
You always come back.
Is that Thunderdome?
I'm gonna drop in Thunderdome.
This is what I do.
I would drop at Thunderdome and then go to Skulltown the third- Oh my god, we can fight on the Thunderdome!
Oh my god, I miss Thunderdome.
I'm alone.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Thunderdome.
Oh, Thunderdome!
Let's go!
Let's all die in Thunderdome!
It's nostalgia bait.
It's literally nostalgia bait right now.
And I'm all for it!
I'm gonna- I eat that shit up!
Oh my god, they know exactly what I want.
Oh my god.
And they know what I want.
Ah, fuck you.
I get baited.
That's fine.
Bait me all you want.
I'm falling for it.
It doesn't matter.
Feed me!
Oh, I forgive you, Apex, for every other bad shit you've done.
This is all I care about.
Oh my god, it's R400 now.
The bait's too good.
It's too good.
Oh my god, I love Thunderdome.
Thunderdome!
Oh my god, Peacekeeper!
I just need wingman!
Or I die!
Yeah, slide punching is back.
Punch boost is back.
Watch.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
They know what I like.
And I will- I will get baited.
I don't care.
They can bait me all they want.
I'm weak.
Oh, I'm so weak!
Oh my god.
They know exactly.
This is- I am the target audience.
No!
They're so low!
Please!
Pathfinder, don't be a little bitch!
They're so low!
It's literally lifeline!
I'm so safe.
Watson, Watson, Watson, are you support?
You're support, right?
Come on.
No, he's not support.
I fucked up.
No!
I forgot.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I think I did pretty well, though.
There was just a lot more people.
Oh, there's more?!
Okay, that's not fair.
He got an R9.
He's got- Oh, the class perks don't exist!
Oh, fuck.
You're right.
I forgot.
The class perks don't exist.
Oh, I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling the skill coming back in me right now.
I'm feeling it, guys.
Bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
Damn.
That means we're back to old lifeline.
I don't remember what season lifeline was.
What does season 1 lifeline have?
Remember?
It's been so long.
What was season 1 lifeline?
Shield unrest?
Oh, the shield!
Okay.
Okay, heal him.
Wait, season 1 lifeline was meta.
I remember now.
Oh my god, it's coming back to me.
Season 1 lifeline.
Oh, fuck.
Season 1.
Oh, fuck this place.
Season 1 lifeline.
That was meta.
And then I'll just heal and ring until everybody's dead.
Do you remember?
When everyone just healed and zoned for season 1 lifeline.
That was literally the only thing people did.
I'm back.
She was everything I wanted.
That is not true.
The new lifeline is so much better.
I feel like.
I think new lifeline.
New lifeline shit is so strong.
The zone ratting.
It's time.
It's time, guys.
I'm gonna queue solo in one of the games and then I'm just gonna stay in zone.
I'm gonna do it.
What the fuck?
How?
Alright.
This is a little awkward.
Oh, I think these guys are gamers.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is bad.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I hope you're helping.
Where are they?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I'm getting crossed so hard.
Alright.
I know what to do, guys.
Wait.
Yeah, I got cross fired.
Okay, guys.
This is it.
I know what to do.
Oh, there's no field.
Damn it.
Fuck.
Okay.
I was gonna do the zone ratting.
I was just gonna play like...
Cause I assume ring damage is season one ring damage too.
So season one ring damage for those who don't remember you can literally just stay in the zone as lifeline and just heal until everybody's dead.
So that was what's in my head.
I was like, oh my god.
I could do that again.
I could actually just stay in the zone and not care.
People get through the day and then that's when ring damage was introduced.
Stronger ring damage was introduced.
Oh my god.
I need to get cough drops.
I don't know why, but today I'm coughing way more than yesterday.
But I ran out of cough drops like two days ago.
Cause I thought I was getting better.
And then like for some reason today there's something about today that my coughing is worse now.
No,
I don't think I have the flu.
I think it's just my throat today is just not feeling it.
I'm definitely gonna order some cough drops before the collab though.
No, it started in the morning before my dance classes.
Yeah, the Chinese throat medicine.
I might take some of that too to thicken my throat.
Alright.
Oh my god, this is so weird.
It's actually so fucking weird looking at this right now.
I'm gonna go here.
Fuck it.
We're gonna go to we're gonna go to market.
We go to market, we kill people in market and then we go to Skull Town.
Oh my god.
Yes, the OG!
Alright, this is where war starts.
This is...
This is literally...
I fucked up war guys.
I fucked up.
War did not go so well.
Yep, nice.
Okay.
He doesn't have what I want.
Oh, please.
Please.
I don't have armor.
Wait, I can just...
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I didn't see the bamboozle.
I don't have a lot of ammo right now.
Okay.
Four bullets and a fucking dream.
Lifeline, are you okay?
I think she's okay.
Okay.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Lifeline, please.
I'm scared.
Oh, Lifeline, please.
Oh, fuck.
Yes, okay.
Get me out of here!
Okay.
It's fine.
What do you want me to do?
The Lifeline should be helping, not me.
I assumed the Lifeline was gonna help, but I guess not.
Alright.
Alright!
Lifeline, are you gonna help?
Lifeline!
She literally watched!
Oh my god!
Oh, you're happy!
Not my problem.
Oh my god.
I still don't have a shield.
I still don't think I...
Oh my god, it's time!
I just need...
I have R-401!
I'm so close to an R-401!
Oh my, here we go.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Look at that.
We're almost close to R-401, guys.
I definitely need more ammo.
Okay.
Oh!
I don't wanna...
I already tried the wingman today.
I wanna do the R... I need R-9.
I haven't found...
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, JK.
JK.
Oh, the Peacekeeper feels so good, too.
Oh my god.
Guys, even the Peacekeeper feels so good.
The original Peacekeeper.
Oh my god.
But...
I'm gonna hold on to the carbine for the R-9.
I'm so happy.
No, you don't understand.
I'm actually so happy.
I'm...
You know...
This is like the apex I fell in love with.
Like...
No!
The way they tweaked the Peacekeeper is not...
They tweaked the Peacekeeper so much that it doesn't feel as good as it is like back then.
Because like old...
I have like so much muscle memory from old Peacekeeper that the new Peace...
Oh my god.
Are they testing the fire alarm?
That was sick, though.
Okay, not gonna lie.
That was pretty sick, though.
Oh my god.
I feel like...
Because I'm back to Season 1, I feel like I actually got better.
I'm like locked back in to like old Toki.
Like my entire...
My Season 1 muscle memory is like kicking in right now.
Even though like...
To be fair, I didn't actually start playing this game until Season 2.
But I still played this game a little bit during Season 1.
Just not as committed as I was.
Oh my god.
Old Toki woke up.
She was like, it's time.
It's time.
Return to your roots.
Oh, it's so time.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Fuck!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Carbine Mastiff just hits harder.
It's just...
Oh my god.
OG Mastiff.
I remember beating...
When I did Rank and I bumped into TSM back then.
Old TSM.
I like killed them with this.
I killed them with this gun right here.
Right here.
I 1v3'd TSM with this.
Oh my god!
Why are they still testing?
I don't understand!
How can they still be testing?
Oh my god.
Get this over with.
Let's go to the other side.
Oh, we can't.
I feel like we should.
Oh, he's so low.
He's actually so low.
I'll thirst him for you.
I'm just gonna go here.
Where are they?
I hear them.
I hear them below me.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh my god!
This area!
Oh, I remember now.
I remember this area.
I was like, this area- Oh my god, this area was so fucked.
This area was actually so fucking annoying.
I remember.
I was just like, this part.
This fucking- Sorry, Lifeline.
Good luck.
Oh my god.
Please don't look at me.
Please don't look at me from above.
No!
I didn't want to chase.
But then our Lifeline was like, okay, but what if we did chase?
And I was like, you know what?
I believe in my Lifeline.
I was just like, you know what?
Surely, our Lifeline wouldn't fuck me over.
I thought about it.
I was like, this is a bad idea.
This is such a bad idea.
I should- I don't- I never believe.
Never believe in your Lifeline.
I forgot.
Number one.
Never believe in your Lifeline.
Never believe in your team.
Your team is always wrong.
I thought he had a plan.
He was so ready.
He looked like he knew he had his shit together.
But I was wrong.
Nobody ever has their shit together.
Mmm.
23 seasons actually and I still trust them.
Wait!
Does this mean aim assist doesn't work on smokes anymore?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
If I play Bangalore, does that mean even smokes don't work now?
For real?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just curious.
Have you asked your apartment to change your air filter since you moved in?
An old filter could be the reason you're coughing.
I don't know.
I think I don't- I think my throat is just uh...
My throat just feels like weird today.
Alright.
You guys do your thing.
Oh my god.
I remember this was hell.
Crossing this pit.
Crossing this was actually like why is this there?
Oh hey!
Hey dad!
Why are you here?
Alright.
I have to play Wraith guys.
Wraith is so good in season 1.
It was literally like- there was a reason why bald Wraiths were a thing.
Okay.
Yep.
That's- ooh!
That's a good old season 1 loot!
If I didn't see it.
Oh my god.
Good old season 1 loot pool.
Woooo!
Man!
I sure do love getting that thing.
Aw man.
That's the season 1 loot pool that I loved!
Yep!
That's season 1!
Old season- yay!
I love getting that thing!
Alright.
He's just looking at me.
I don't know why he's here.
I guess he heard the testing and he didn't like it.
Oh my god, please.
Sakuragi, please.
I'm right here.
Oh, I look so restable!
Restable!
Look at me go!
It's not like there's anybody here.
Okay, what will you get out of that?
What do you get?
Where's my three white shields in a bin?
Guys, I literally had no loot.
You can't- I couldn't do anything, guys.
I couldn't.
I can't believe this is not- I can't believe I'm getting unimmersed from season 1, because I can queue in the loading screen.
How have I got zero R9s?
I swear, I found every gun, except for an R9.
I literally have not found an R9 in this entire game.
I've been playing for like an hour, and I still have no R9.
Like, how is that possible?
Actually, how is that possible?
I need my R9 and a sniper scout on my G7 scout, so I can be like- so I can actually be annoying.
So I can actually bring back- That's how I got- That's how I got bread.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
I was a- was a dirty G7 scout abuser.
That's fucking right.
I own that shit.
I picked up a G7 scout, put a sniper scope on there, and then go pew pew pew pew pew.
That was me.
And then I end the top 500.
That was so- And you know damn well, I abused the charge- Oh no, charge rifle isn't back.
I was gonna say- I was also the charge rifle abuser.
That's fucking right.
Charge rifle and then they nerfed charge rifle.
So I went to the G7 scout.
They can't stop me.
They couldn't stop me.
You have no shade?
Where's your top 500?
Sorry, can't hear you over the lack of a top 500.
That's fucking right.
You only hate me cause I played the meta.
You were part of the problem.
You gotta be part of the problem if you want anything in life.
Can they really blame me?
What?
How am I supposed to- Oh my- What?
Oh, I had no armor.
I had no armor.
I was like, how?
I was like, one shot?
I forgot.
I don't come on with armor.
I don't.
I didn't go in with armor.
Okay, look.
I forgot the fire rate.
Guys, it's been a while playing wingman, guys.
Look, guys.
All I'm saying is that I didn't have the G7 scout or the R9 on me, guys.
I didn't have the G7 scout or the R9.
That's why.
That's the only reason.
If I had those two guns, it would've been over.
It would've been over.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you're right.
Wait, give me a sec.
Wait, since we're in retro land, wait, you're right.
You're actually right.
If we're in retro land, we gotta actually go retro.
Back to the OG times.
I wonder if it's still over.
Okay, I think it's this one.
Is this a...
Is this a new...
I don't remember if...
This is?
Yeah, I think so.
Wait, which one is the...
Which one is my old...
We're time traveling now.
We're gonna time travel.
Okay, yeah.
This one is this one.
I had to make sure.
It's been so long.
I was like, wait, is this the right one?
I don't remember.
Where the fuck is it?
Okay, hockey name.
Oh, is it this?
There we go.
It's been so long.
We're actually...
I'm fucking huge.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Okay, there we go.
Now that should work.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I'll fix this later because I'm in-game now.
Now we're actually back.
Oh, man.
Back when Mozambique was fucking terrible.
Please.
Thank you.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God.
There's way too many people.
There's way too many...
Oh, the fucking charge for this is fucking with me a lot right now.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'll block this.
I'll block this door.
You go handle the other one.
What?
How?
No!
There's too many!
Okay, now I can fix myself.
Give me a sec.
Fix myself.
Okay, now we're okay.
Now we're okay.
Now we're back for real.
Okay, give me a sec.
Now...
Now we're back for real.
It's retro mode.
We're back in retro hours.
Oh, wait.
Hello, hello, everybody.
Now we're actually back in retro hours.
Oh, my God.
Not the boys.
What do you guys mean?
We're time traveling.
We're back in season one.
Yeah, this is retro Doki.
Back in season one Apex Legends.
Are you guys ready to game?
Not that.
What do you mean?
Am I back in 2021?
Spark Knights, are you guys ready for some more Apex Legends, Spark Knights?
Doki before she saw the real world.
Spark Knights, assemble!
That's right!
Can we get some Spark Knights in chat real quick?
Can we get some Spark Knights in chat?
Doki before the dark times.
Before the empire.
Time for the daily song.
Alright, here we go.
We can have a good game, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the donation.
Thank you.
Here's a butthurt.
Redeeming the daily song.
I think I'm lost.
Mochi, thank you for the super chat.
Only OGs remember the butthurt.
Only OGs remember.
Oh wait, did I zoom in?
God damn it, I forgot to turn it off.
Okay, that was my bad, sorry.
Guys, I'm gonna ruin your immersion real quick.
Guys, I need to ruin your immersion.
Because I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I forgot to turn that off.
That's classic Doki right there.
Right there.
Alright, where are we going?
Where are we going?
My immersion!
Guys, Retro Doki did not care about the immersion.
Classic Retro stuff.
Just so you guys know, Retro Doki did not give a fuck.
Retro Doki was just trying to do her best.
Oh my god!
It's over.
It's over, but like...
It's so over.
Yes!
Retro Doki is happy.
Retro Doki is so happy.
Where the fuck is he?
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
I fucking see you.
Hey.
Nice.
Wait, give me a sec.
I need to fix myself.
Retro Doki is going through a lot right now.
I keep fucking it up.
I keep zooming in.
Give me a sec.
I keep accidentally zooming in.
I need to turn that off.
Alright.
Now, we're actually ready.
Oh my god.
Guys, I got my R9.
It's over.
I got the R9 Peacekeeper.
Oh my god.
If I didn't have the collab, I would play longer.
I would definitely play so much more.
Maybe Gorilla Stream?
Who knows?
I don't know.
It just feels so fun.
Playing Classic Apex Season 1.
It's just...
It's nostalgia bait.
But by god, it's working.
It's working on me.
They know what I want.
This was literally made for me.
This is...
This is literally made for me.
I was the target audience for this.
Back when I played 8 plus hours everyday.
It feels just like home.
I was very depressed, but like...
Nothing's changed.
Alright.
Nice.
I haven't been able to do bunnyhop healing because fights that go by so fucking fast.
Alright.
Let me grab this.
I need a 401.
Oh my god.
I need an R401.
I need to get a 301 so I get an R40400.
What are you talking about?
There's no dad.
It was just Doki Doge.
What are you talking about?
There was no dad.
It's the Barkknights Dragoons.
Who are the Dragoons?
Who are the Dragoons, guys?
It's the Barkknights.
Pre-dad era.
Who's dad?
There's only Doki...
I'm sorry.
There's only Doki Doge.
Who's dad?
Barkknights, are you guys okay?
I don't know why you're talking about... Oh my god.
Six shield cells.
What are you talking about?
I'm Doki Maplebird.
Overwatch 2?
That sounds crazy.
They'll never make an Overwatch 2, guys.
Oh my god.
Did you guys hear about that?
Whoa!
Oh, they heard.
They definitely heard, though.
They heard.
They heard whatever I was...
As if they'll... Yeah, as if they'll make an Overwatch 2.
They gotta fix goats first before they make Overwatch 2.
Are you serious?
Another squad?
Okay.
Got it.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, there's...
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
I hope that's ours.
I actually...
Oh, no.
Oh, that's fine.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, there's another team.
Let's go in.
I think that's gonna happen to us.
I have a portal.
I don't remember old portal.
I just remember portal was cool.
Whoa, what the...
Okay, nice.
We got the lifeline.
Third party?
That's fucking right.
This is old R9, bitch!
This is the old R9!
You're in my world!
No!
Don't fuck... Oh, god.
I'm lagging.
That's fucking right!
Welcome to my world!
Alright.
Nice.
That felt good.
I swear I heard a Wraith queue somewhere.
Where is that Wraith?
I know you're around.
I swear there was a Wraith queue.
Just like old times.
Pastuki, I don't have much time.
I'm at 21 dollars.
What?
Don't what?
What is it?
What should I not do?
Hey, guys.
Oh, my god.
Did you guys saw the new Hololive EN debut?
I just watched your debut last week.
You're so cool.
Oh, my god.
Oh,
my god.
That shark girl when she started her stream with Ah.
Oh, my god.
That's crazy.
Hololive EN has an EN brand.
They literally just debuted last week.
It was so cool.
Um...
No, Doki, no!
Oh, my god.
It's really cool.
I never expected there gonna be like an actual like English branch for like... Oh, my god.
Wait.
Back to the good old days.
Alright.
Guys.
Oh, my god.
Do you guys think like...
Do you guys think VTubing is gonna like grow bigger?
Cool.
Maple, no!
It's a canon event.
You can't stop it, guys.
It's too late.
It's a canon event.
Oh, my god.
Me and my 10 viewers.
Thanks, Sparkknights.
I really appreciate you guys coming in to watch me.
Me and my 10 viewers.
Oh, my god.
Thank you for the subscription.
Thank you for subscribing.
Have a good heart.
What do we do?
Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe our Bangalore...
Wait.
What is that?
What is that heirloom?
Bangalore doesn't have an heirloom.
Where did he get... Is he a hacker, guys?
How did he have that heirloom?
They've only just released the Wraith heirloom like...
Last month.
Like, how does he have an heirloom?
And why is it like a giant version of the Kunai?
He must be a dev.
You're right.
It must be a...
He's hacking.
Oh, my god.
He has a giant knife.
That doesn't exist.
Maybe he's a dev.
Redeeming for the song of the day.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I have a 2x4 on my R9.
I'm so cursed.
I forgot how fucking cursed that shit was.
You're in my territory.
You're in my world.
GR9!
Now you guys know how I got top 500.
Now you know.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
Where?
Okay.
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Wait, I need the 2x4, actually.
Where was that rez?
Oh, it's above us.
Okay, let's go.
Let's see.
Should I get the- I feel like- Ah, fuck it.
Let's do it.
Let's full commit.
Let's actually bring it back.
Let's bring it back.
There we go.
Oh, man.
Poor guys.
Where's that Bangalore?
I know you're here.
I know you're here, Bangalore.
Where are you?
I don't know.
Huh?
What?
Bangalore?
Bangalore, where did you go?
Little guy!
Where did the little guy go?
Oh, fuck it.
The little guy can't do anything anyway.
Might as well leave.
That little guy can't do shit.
Goodbye, little guy.
Look, I got my Pred badge right here.
Wait.
Got my Pred thing here.
And I got my Pred right here.
Yeah.
That's so cute, right?
That's how it happened.
Got OGR9.
Forgot how fucking broken OGR9 was.
Holy shit.
That guy got fucking shredded.
And I had a 2x4.
I had a fucking 2x4 scope.
That should not have worked.
That actually should not have worked.
Hello?
Where are you guys?
I know one of you is a solo.
And the other one has to be...
I guess the other team has to be a full team.
There's no way it's like two...
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Hunting in this map is so difficult.
I don't remember what the pathways were in Season 1.
Oh, they're up here?
They're up here?
Oh, they are.
They are.
Oh my god, look at him go.
He's infinitely jumping.
Oh fuck.
Okay, don't.
Don't watch.
Don't watch that.
That was an accident.
That was an accident, guys.
It was just a prank.
Oh, it was just a prank, guys.
Guys, it's cause I have a 2x4.
I'm more used to 3x.
Guys, it's cause I needed a 3x, guys.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Fucking wingman though.
Alright.
How far are they?
Okay, I need high ground on this.
I was just being silly.
I was just being silly, guys.
Wait.
There we go.
No more being silly.
No more being silly, guys.
Oh my god.
He was actually one though.
No more being silly for real.
Not being silly anymore.
More being silly.
No more being silly.
No more.
Silliness is over.
Rest in peace, those guys.
That's fucking right.
I'm no longer playing anymore.
I'm peak-doki with my R9.
I'm peak -doki with my R9.
Look at that!
The first time!
I find an R9!
Oh.
I do?
Where?
I got...
I got looked at by the enemy though.
Where is it?
He's here somewhere.
He's scoped in.
He's here.
He's scoped.
But pretty eyes.
Fucking easy.
So fucking easy.
How did you see that?
I told you.
Got my R9.
Back to the good old days.
I'm back, baby.
I'm fucking back.
That's...
That's how I got top 500.
At least the bathroom chat.
Back.
I'm fucking back, guys.
I'm back in more ways than one right now.
Oh my god.
I'm sad that this is not in rank.
I wish they could bring that...
I wish they would bring it back just for rank.
If it was just for rank, it would be so fun.
I think it would be really fun to have OG Apex Season 1 back.
Just for fun.
Too bad.
Too bad we don't.
Yeah, they should!
I feel like they should make this mode.
If they can have arenas, why can't we have this?
If they make this stupid arenas...
I like how somebody was like, I want arena back.
And I was like, if they could have that stupid arena mode for rank, I would like this to be a rank mode too.
Just roll back everything.
Who cares?
This was more fun anyway.
I wish.
Aw man.
I do wish they would bring...
I wish this was a rank mode.
I think people would have so much fun.
Doing this for rank mode.
Especially with punch boosting.
Punch boosting and...
And bunny hopping.
It's like skill stuff are back.
It was more like PC related movement stuff too.
I feel like it would be so fun.
Oh man.
Catalyst!
Derpy Lake!
Oh yes.
It's time.
Now to actually be annoying.
I need a sniper scope for this.
And then I can actually...
Terrorize.
Terrorize the lobby.
Alright, we need a sniper scope.
And it's over.
It's so over.
Alright, there's nothing here.
Oh yeah, there shouldn't be anything here.
It's apex 1 loot table.
I wish they didn't reverse that.
They shouldn't have...
They shouldn't have reversed it.
They know it was garbage.
It's like...
Everything but the loot.
I'm trying to find armor.
There's no armor.
There's no armor anywhere.
It looks like I fucking ran past like 20 armors.
I don't...
I haven't found...
But I don't want.
It's not fair.
I want to pick and choose.
Alright.
You have to get through the olyx.
You have to get through.
It's either all of them or none of them.
Doki.
Oh god.
Well, that was fast.
Wow.
Why are you taking the zip?
Are you stupid?
Oh my god, I have to stay here.
Okay.
There's an armor swap right here.
So I need to play around this area.
Where is he?
Wait, no, there's an armor swap right here.
As long as I play around...
Oh my god, there's 200 armor swaps.
I hear the octane.
Okay, I'm going to play around here.
For the armor swaps.
Oh my god.
Where are they?
Okay.
Are you serious?
I hear them, but like...
Haha, JK.
Oh my god.
That was like 20 different armor swaps that I took.
Haha.
Okay.
That's like the only way to win that fight.
I just had to use the armor swaps.
Okay, I need to get this G7 scout.
I can't clutch with a G7 scout.
Alright, goodbye.
Mwah.
That's what I used to do.
Just stand there, 200 armor.
And then be like, swap, swap, swap.
It was how you came.
I still got it.
I still got it in me.
I still remember the strat.
Haha.
Yeah, exactly.
It's basically a purple armor, exactly.
Yeah, everything is like the original.
Okay, do I even have a helmet?
I do.
Okay, let me get my syringe up.
Just like how it should be played.
That was how it should have been played.
Guys, fuck, okay?
Okay.
That's fucking right, idiot.
Fucking stupid.
What are you, fucking stupid?
Oh my god.
Yeah, fucking get rezzed.
Rezz yourself and do it again.
I fucking dare you.
Peek me again, you whore.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Oh, he is trying to peek me again.
Yeah, woah, woah, woah.
Fucking stupid.
Learn how to aim.
Thank you.
Alright, nice.
He had purple armor too.
He should not have lost that.
That's actually so embarrassing.
I mean, I could.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe he is stupid.
Alright.
Here we go again.
Let's go the other way.
Bloodhound, what are you doing?
I'm clearly running away from you.
Bloodhound, I have zero heals.
Oh my god.
Bloodhound.
Oh my god, Bloodhound.
Oh my god.
Like, why did he run that way?
I don't have 500 white armor.
To do this trick again.
Like, I was in Skulltown.
You can only do this trick in Skulltown.
Literally, Skulltown is like the only place you can do the trick.
Because there is like 200 white armors there.
Oh, you guys are so dumb.
Oh my god.
You guys are fucking stupid.
Oh, he would have been dead if I had a...
Um...
Fucking...
Like, stolen him again.
Oh my god.
Oh, and you're fucking rolling.
Of course you are.
Get shit on.
Dumb teammates.
No, that never changes.
It's still the same.
It's always been like that, guys.
It's never changed.
Stupid teammates are still the same.
Sorry, guys.
It's okay.
I'm so happy that like...
Um...
Oh my god, guys.
I can't believe Apex...
We're in season one of Apex, guys.
Do you think this game is gonna grow big, guys?
I know like I just came from Overwatch, but...
I think this game is getting...
Is really addicting so far.
I'm not sure yet.
I think like...
Wraith is like...
Right now is my favorite.
I heard they're planning on making a competitive like esports team for Apex.
And like TSM is planning on signing a team soon.
I wonder who's gonna be in it.
Do you think Ace is gonna be in it?
Guys, did you hear about this kid named Dizzy?
He's so good with the wingman.
I've been watching Dizzy.
I've been watching Dizzy with his wingman.
And oh my god, he's so good.
I just hope they...
Wig?
Who's Nice Wig?
Never heard of that guy before.
No, too far back!
Go back!
I've only heard of Dizzy.
I've been watching Dizzy and Ace.
Oh, what the fuck?
Whoa.
Okay.
Yeah, I've only heard of Ace and Dizzy.
Dizzy and his wingman.
He makes wingman look so easy.
I wish I could aim like that, honestly.
He has purple armor off rip?!
Hello.
That's fucked up.
I can't believe he had purple armor off rip.
I'm trying to figure out where he would go.
Wingman is stupid.
Oh, feels just like...
What the?
He whiffed it.
Where is he?
Stand here.
Put your shield up!
Oh, he doesn't have knockdown.
There's a Wraith.
Yeah, I see him.
I see him.
Oh, he's...
How do you whiff that again?
He died!
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
We lived...
We lived past the...
It's okay.
We survived longer than the Pathfinder.
He fucking died for that.
Fuck that Pathfinder.
Bro, it felt like the...
I like how...
I like how he was like...
Wingman is so fucking...
Feels just like season 1.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I do hope they release Titanfall 3 after this though.
It's so cool that they made a Battle Royale off of Titanfall 2.
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait for them to focus on Titanfall 3 right after...
After releasing...
After...
No, Ducky, stop!
Don't you...
What?
What, guys?
It's only 2021.
What's going on?
No.
Why must you do this?
It's just 2021.
What's going on, Farknights?
What's going on?
If they can do this for their free Battle Royale...
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait to see what they're gonna do for it by Titanfall 3.
Oh my god.
Yeah, did you see this trailer for Silksong?
I heard it's coming out like next year.
Time showed no mercy.
Oh my god.
They were showing it at like E3.
No, stop!
Oh my god, I love E3.
I hope we get another...
I hope we get E3 this year.
Oh my...
Are you guys excited for E3 this year?
I'm so excited.
I hope it doesn't get cancelled or anything.
And even if it does get cancelled...
I bet it's gonna come back next year.
Stop.
I'll just come back next year, guys.
E3 is always here.
Doki, did you...
Are you okay, Doki?
Who hurt you?
Like...
That guy.
That guy hurt me.
I couldn't even...
Oh my god, I couldn't even run past...
Good old Apex.
Feels just like home.
Good old Skulltown.
Just like I never left.
Feels like I never left Skulltown.
Oh, man.
I love crossing...
I love crossing the gate.
School is out for two weeks.
Yay!
Oh my god.
This thing's changed.
Now that's the Skulltown we love.
Two weeks!
Oh my god!
I heard some people...
Don't have to go to school for like...
Just two weeks, guys.
I'm just gonna die down soon.
I mean, it's just a cold, right?
We don't even know what year.
We're like stuck in this weird...
We don't even know what year or month it is anymore.
It's just somewhere.
Somewhere in Apex Season 1.
Oh,
man.
What is this time paradox?
We've gone far too back.
Go back!
Go back, Doki!
We're too far!
Go back!
This hurts too bad.
She's coughing, guys!
Doki, did you see a doctor?
What are you guys talking about?
It's just a normal cold.
Alright.
Buy a toilet paper.
No, Doki!
Don't do it!
Get the hand sanitizer, Doki!
Nice, I got my white armor.
Oh, my armor.
I would like...
Camp inside this room.
On top of this.
This is how you farm.
You close the door.
Oh, fuck.
Nevermind.
We can't fuck around right now.
Where did he...
Oh, over there.
Over there, okay.
Alright, I was gonna show you guys my...
My way of camping, people.
My gamer.
My rat skills.
Oh, my god.
I'm like not...
I'm lowkey like not used to Carbine.
The Carbine spray.
The Carbine spray is so weird sometimes.
Nice.
I feel like OG Carbine feels a little weird.
I don't know.
OG Carbine doesn't feel the same as the current Carbine.
I have no idea.
I forgot what OG Carbine and like the...
Yeah, it's a bit wacky.
The tracking for it is a bit wacky versus the current Carbine.
Okay.
Go back!
That's too far back!
Yeah, Mozamb... Mozamb's trash.
100% agree.
I 100% agree.
One guy is missing from that team.
I didn't full kill him.
So he's hiding somewhere.
One of them is hiding.
I know for sure.
Cause I didn't get full kill on him.
Oh, I hear him.
No, that was me.
Whoops.
That was me, guys.
I heard myself.
I like Alternator more versus OG Carbine.
I swear to god.
I wish they did bring this rank mode back.
Cause I know I know the third is still alive.
Okay.
We gotta go over there.
Alright.
Off we go.
God, I miss this map.
I miss this map.
We need to get an R9.
The moment we get an R9, it's actually like we're set.
We're set for life.
We literally just need an R9.
Doki, you got any sponsors yet?
I swear I feel like I get sponsors like every week.
Which is so- Which is really nice.
I'm so greedy with sponsors.
Oh my god.
I was like, this is not Octane area.
I was like, what is this place?
I forgot this area.
End zone here was fucking terrible.
I hated end zone here.
Cause you can be anywhere.
Uh...
What was I talking about?
I don't remember what I was talking about.
Oh yeah!
Cause I never had the opportunity to get sponsors a lot.
It was so rare for me to get sponsors.
Now I'm so fucking greedy.
They'll be like, do you want a sponsor?
And I don't even hesitate.
I'm just like, yes.
Yes, I do.
Yes.
Give me all of it.
I'm so greedy.
She sold out.
I've been selling out since the- Okay.
Alright, I've been selling out since the beginning.
Who do you think you're talking to?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh no!
Doesn't help.
No!
If only I had an- What?
He was actually- Oh, he was okay.
He was rolling.
Oh, it feels just like season one.
Feels just like season one.
Looking at him, standing still at my box.
Oh, it doesn't hurt any less.
Does not hurt any less.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, my heart.
My fucking heart.
The moment I get done R9, we win.
It's just that easy.
Honestly, that's all I need.
I just need a goddamn R9.
Like, R9 is the way to go!
It's literally- It's literally it!
We win when I get R9!
It really is just that easy.
Like, nope, they can't do anything.
I literally have aimbot when I have an R9.
It's just- Like, I just locked in.
I think I found the R9 once.
Only one time.
This entire- I've been playing for almost two hours and we found the R9 one time.
Like, what in the world?
Where are we?
Where the fuck are we?
Where are you?
I don't know!
Did you guys saw the R9 literally one time?
Oh my god, it's time.
I should've went caustic.
I should've went caustic and bunkered up.
Sounds exactly like season one.
If only I went caustic and bunkered up.
Okay.
It's time.
Oh my god, it's time.
Oh my god, it's time!
But I have no ammo!
I have no ammo!
I have zero ammo!
It's time, but where's the ammo?
Like, are you serious?
Are you- This guy took all the light!
Do you wanna win?
Do you wanna win, you stupid lifeline?
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, thank god.
Alright, okay.
Alright, let's go.
They have to fly down.
They're gonna drop, right?
I'm gonna wait for one of them to drop down.
They'll drop down, right?
Maybe they'll drop down.
I'm hunting.
Shh, be very quiet.
I'm hunting for players.
Oh shit, nevermind.
Oh, nevermind, okay.
Where?
Oh, this is two different- this is a full- Oh!
Wait, what the fuck?
This is not fair!
It's a full team?!
Okay.
Look, all I'm saying is that I have to fight different people and my teammate- My- Where did our third go?
Oh, there was a fucking other team behind us!
Oh my god!
Okay, look, there was another team behind us.
I hit every shot I could!
There was three of them!
I hit every shot there was in my mag!
I did hit those!
Oh, Doki could've won V5!
Oh, Doki needs to rest.
Doki shouldn't be playing for so long.
No, that's a lie.
Doki would be at 8 hours now.
OG Doki would've been at her 8th hour mark.
She would've been there for launch so she could grind rank instantly.
She would've been like, It's rank time!
Play rank on launch so you can get to Pred first and get a lead.
Not Pred first, but you get a lead so you don't have to worry about grinding later.
Alright.
LG!
This is LG, guys!
We gotta prep for the other stream.
God, it's so fun though.
I might stream more Season 1 Apex.
I don't know!
It's just really fun.
I've been really enjoying Season 1 Apex a lot.
I would?
I would Gorilla stream today, but like my schedule this week is so fucking bad that I don't want to overdo it.
I don't want to I don't want to overdo it.
I have so many streams this week and so many commitments and stuff.
I wish I could.
The timing was just so bad.
It's such a fun game mode.
It's just fun to play the guns that I love the most.
You know?
I just really miss the R9.
I really miss R9, Wingman, and Peacekeeper.
I actually used to run R9 P.K.
When you're in a team, your team handles long range.
But I used to run R9 P.K.
when I played Ranked.
My Wingman was not good enough to run Wingman P.K.
I mean, it's still not.
It's not as good as my Ranked buddies, so I would just run R9.
I knew my strengths.
I knew what I'm good at.
I wanted to thirst him.
Just because I can.
Oh, you were the champion?
That's fucking right.
Get thirsted.
We have no armor!
I have no armor, I just realized.
There we go.
Got armor.
Almost.
That was close.
I legit almost forgot about the armor bullshit.
It's been so long.
Alright, I'll go this way.
I hear them.
Right behind me.
Oh, that's a different squad?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm gonna go to my team then.
Oh no, oh no!
No!
Oh my god, that was close.
Oh, they're fighting.
That's good.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Sorry, I had to do this.
Sorry, buddy.
You were scaring me.
And now, we're out in the open.
We're out in the open.
That was scary, bro.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Alright, let's go.
They're like right in front of me.
He's like right here.
Oh?
I hear you.
You're right below me.
I hear you right below me.
Oh, what?
Where's that sniper?
Oh my god, that little bitch.
Just a little sniper right here.
Oh, come on!
You're such a little bitch!
There's a Gibby right here.
But I feel like...
Yeah, I was gonna say, I feel like the other team is gonna push us now.
There we go.
We got one of them.
Come on.
I know your teammate's here.
I know your teammate is right there Why am I waiting?
Oh, you scanned me.
Oh, that's another team.
That's...
That's not who I wanted.
Fucking idiot.
Oh no.
It's time to leave.
There we go.
Yeah.
Is it okay to go back up?
Well, let's see.
Oh no, not the other squad.
Wait, there's another team?
How many teams are there?
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
This is bad.
This is very bad.
I gotta take this then.
Give me a sec!
We have nothing!
Oh god,
you're ledge jumping?
That doesn't exist in season one, you cheater!
All I'm saying is that...
Ledge jumping did not exist.
You're actually cheating if you're ledge jumping.
That wasn't a thing.
I fucking...
Okay.
Oh wait, that's my team.
No!
One more, last one for real.
This guy's cheating!
Ledge jumping didn't exist!
That was a move...
Nobody knew that movement tech yet!
Nobody...
Nobody knew that movement tech!
Doki is such a hater.
He's not...
I'm unimmersed now.
I'm unimmersed.
I'm not immersed anymore.
That guy ruined it for me.
He ruined it for me.
Check his PC!
That's not allowed!
That wasn't real!
Season one was all about bee hopping!
Okay, Punch Boosting was like season four or some shit.
Or season five.
He invented the tech...
Yeah, he's Sniper Monkey!
I don't think so.
Back to 2024.
We're gonna grab you back to 2024.
If it's allowed.
It's the last thing we do.
We're gonna yoink you back in time.
No!
It shouldn't exist!
We can't have that!
They should remove all the other movement tech!
To be fair, I was tap strafing this entire time.
Tap strafing did not exist.
To be fair, I've actually been tap strafing the last two hours.
They don't know that.
We're gonna have my...
Toki was cheating!
I invented tap strafing!
It's not cheating if I invented it just now.
I literally invented it in season one.
I didn't tell anybody.
I wanted the game to stay pure.
I knew when tap strafing...
Became public...
It would ruin the entire ecosystem of Apex.
So I kept quiet.
I kept quiet.
Okay.
Alright.
Time to go die.
I'm not late for my collab.
But think of the YouTube guide video!
You don't know the hell you'll unleash...
When you bring out tap strafing...
To the public, guys.
It's 2021.
You don't know how bad...
The Apex esport community is gonna get...
When you include tap strafing...
Into the mix.
I can see the future now.
All those roleplayers...
Complaining that they can't emulate tap strafing.
And then they start to realize...
Wait, I can start scripting.
And then actually have aim assist...
And PC movement.
Like MNK movement.
And that's the hell I don't want to unleash in the world.
I did everything I could...
To save us.
The dark age is...
If people know about what tap strafing was...
Scripting is gonna start running rampant.
Oh my god!
Of course it had to be a bloodhound that sees me.
Like, out of all...
Really...
Out of any character...
It was a bloodhound.
It could've been any of them.
It literally could've been any other character.
Of course I get scanned...
By the one character that could find out.
That's actually crazy.
What are the odds?
What are the odds that it was a bloodhound?
I'm listening underneath.
It's so quiet.
Hello?
Where the fuck is this team?
This team leave him?
Oh, this team did leave him.
I was like, what?
Guys, don't watch.
I need a 2x4.
Guys, I need a 2x4, it's different.
Guys, I need a 2x4, guys.
Guys, you don't understand.
The moment I get a 2x4, it's over.
Okay.
I realized I did not loot any shields.
Oh my god.
I looted zero shields.
This is bad.
There's not even armor swaps anywhere.
Oh, thank god.
It had to be like that.
Guys, I can't believe it.
I knew I should've looted more.
Guys, I think it's because I didn't loot enough.
Where are they going?
I'm so confused.
They're like not playing near us at all.
Like, what are they trying to do?
Like, what is he...
What?
Why does he want to fight?
No, we fight.
Guys, team.
Okay.
Bro, they're running.
Team, they're not gonna look back.
They're long gone.
We might as well just fight King's Canyon.
It's fine.
We'll just fight King's Canyon.
And then we don't need shields.
We'll just...
Guys, we don't need shields.
We're just gonna absorb all the other shields.
We kill them.
We kill and then take the shields off of the dead.
Like, who needs shields when you can absorb?
That's the plan.
Oh my god, he's actually one.
There we go.
I just had to remember the drop-off.
I just had to remember how to shoot with the G7 because I haven't in a long time.
I literally have not used the G7 in so long.
Alright.
Oh, get back in here Pathfinder.
Get your ass back in here.
Oh my god, maybe not.
Oh shit, I didn't think he was gonna do that.
But okay.
There we go.
As I told you guys, absorb the shield.
Alright, nevermind.
Oh guys, guys.
I need the shields, guys.
Guys.
Oh my god, please.
Guys, there's not enough shields for me to absorb!
I'm running out of absorptions!
I'm running out.
I'm running out!
Oh my god, please.
Oh thank god, I can absorb.
Wait, what?
It's over.
He's in here.
Oh my god, my 3x.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry Lifeline!
Lifeline, please.
I don't have...
Thank god.
I'm running out.
I'm actually running out.
Come on.
Come on!
Please let me stream in 20 minutes!
Oh my god.
No.
Oh thank god, okay.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
I'm sorry!
Oh my god!
Okay guys, we gotta go.
GG's, we're gonna go head to the collab now.
I think the 3x on the R9 was a mistake.
It was...
It was a mistake, guys.
Anyway, that was really fun!
I'm gonna go get ready for the collab, everybody!
If I do feel like it, maybe there will be a collaboration.
I'm not sure yet, because it's a very packed week.
But it was really fun playing the OG Apex again.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Guys, you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Alright, see you guys in like 20 minutes.
Bye bye, guys!
Bye!